he's Jerry West the hall of famer and
now a special consultant to the Clippers
and still sounds strange to have that
title there with the Clippers there
Jerry hello how's everything going
everything is good Dan and thanks for
having me on his show all right what is
your official job well I'm actually very
much like I was when I was involved with
the Warriors six incredible years being
part of something that was really
special and not having to be the
OUTFRONT person was very appealing to me
and it's going to be very much like that
so I'm hopeful that I can help make a
difference you never know that it's
never given but I think everyone is
different than you know you've had a
couple of different opportunities to
move into different areas even though
it's the same field it feels good when
when you're wanted number one but number
two if you feel like you helped make a
difference
frankly I'm even though I'm older I just
don't feel like I'm ready to retire to
be honest wicked I just I have a reason
to get up in the morning I'm back in Los
Angeles with people I know and respect
and I think there's going to be an
incredible owner here and Steve Ballmer
he's fantastic to be around I'll tell
you that what is the first order of
business for you well actually you know
I've had a couple conversations with Doc
and Lawrence pranks who are the two
people that I'm going to be responsible
for to do rather and trying to you know
sometimes you did you don't really
control everything that you would like
to control in terms of player personnel
and I'm talking about the Clippers with
three players that are free agents you
know that's I think the first order of
business and you know we've talked about
that talked about some plans that they
have and some things that they hopefully
and hopefully want to implement but
anyway very much like I was involved
with the Warriors Chris Paul I guess top
of the priority list of knowing what
he's going to do and have you had an
opportunity to reach out to Chris to
find out what what his thoughts are on
staying or
testing free agency you know I really
have and that would be very premature
for me to be honest with you as I say if
a I know Chris unbelievable respect for
him and I just think he's and he's one
of those elite players that come along
every once awhile he and he doesn't he
just plays and he's one have been one of
the not only best point guards in the
league but he's one of the best
defenders at his position that I think
I've ever seen so I'm hopeful that he'll
be part of the Clippers future as
everyone else is over there when you
make a trade are you more likely to make
a trade with somebody that you're
friendly with or is it just you're
trying to get an asset whether you're
friends with the GM or not well you know
I think all the people who have worked
in this league intimately I don't know
some of the some of the younger people
in the league but Lawrence Frank says
the person is going to be dealing those
areas and most people think trades are
made to one game to get an advantage
that's not what the way a trade is
supposed to work and frankly I think I
think it's kind of insulting that if you
called someone you might have two or
three players in one position that
somebody's expendable and somebody might
have the same situation on another team
so if there's a trade it can be worked
out that both sides feel comfortable
with it great afterwards you know people
are going to be made people going to be
curious about why trades are made and
then secondly they're always going to
have the opinion who got the best out of
the deal I never felt that was fair for
either side of the fence regardless of
what player you're acquiring I think
it's a supposed to be a win-win
situation for everyone we look at the
draft differently than we did five years
ten fifteen twenty years ago the
importance of the three-point shot being
able to either shoot it or defend it how
much does that affected the draft
strategy with what these teams are doing
now well I don't know if it affects a
draft strategy but shooting should
always be a premium another team that
scores the most points is going to win
the team plays the smartest is going to
win and I think it really helps to have
players that are multi-talented not just
cores not just offensive players but
versatility is really a key today in
this league and I think again there's
always a team in every era that someone
wants to emulate and now it will be the
Warriors and the Rockets people will
want them played I think one game they
may be money shot 55 3 which is an
incredible amount of three-point shot
and you know there's risk and dangers
with doing that if you're making them
fine but otherwise it's almost
impossible to defend if you're not but I
think right now that the Warriors oh the
teams are the glam routines but to have
three players that can make a lot of
threes and from distances that no one
would even think about taking and making
everyone wants to be like Steph Curry
klay Thompson Kevin Durant because of
their enormous shooting abilities but
you have to have cohesive players and
players that can do a lot of different
things and the Warriors win the
championship because they were
well-rounded team a very good defensive
team for all-stars on one team and so
that's always the goal for other other
people and I think you have to be
realistic of what your chances are to
acquire those kind of play players more
importantly it shows you the productive
the draft can be if you draft the right
players but we get so many young players
in league today and they get a lot of
hype and some of them just don't turn
out to be what everyone wants them to be
and particularly the people who draft
them but in a citation your tail
sometime Dan you know if you have people
that work extremely hard in these
organizations and sometimes they don't
get the results they they want and other
times it's very very important but as
you mentioned Thursday night is time for
hopeful all these teams haven't done
well and obviously it's the most
exciting time to be involved when you
have first-round draft picks and you're
in a position maybe you dress someone
who really like a lot more to someone
else like that's the fun part of it
we're talking to Jerry West who's now an
advisor for the LA Clippers joining
Stan Patrick show and by the way Golden
State that the front office doesn't get
enough credit that you did get Steph
Curry you did take klay Thompson you did
get draymond Green you you made smart
draft picks and you know it benefited
you I know you get Kevin Durant but
stepping back from this as we move
forward are the Warriors good for the
NBA that they're they're that good
Jerry and that you know it might be
predictable that you know they're going
back to an NBA Finals barring an injury
well and then they should go back to NBA
Finals they don't have anything tragic
happen to them this is a young team
right in the right in its prime some of
these players having gotten there yet I
think it's great for the NBA and really
I think if you watch how these players
conduct themselves then it's the most
incredible group of young exciting
players I've ever been around
forget the fact that they the talent and
the fact that they went a lot this
organization really is classic we've got
a classy head coach and Steve Steve Kerr
Bob Myers as good as it gets a wonderful
person a great voice for the franchise
the ownership group oh my gosh
I can't imagine have this many people
who have been successful in own rights
and when you have conference calls with
them it is an ideal situation and things
can change overnight people don't
realize one misstep you know what
something terrible happen things can go
awry very quickly but you'd like to
think they're going to be healthy and go
forward and to me if I were a fan
regardless of where they are I would
have two words that come in town I would
like to watch them play because they
play basketball the correct way passing
the ball moving the ball and in this
league again people follow trends
certainly the people there's people with
all the statistics you know they have
everything that organization can need to
see the weaknesses of their team it's a
great training for young kids who
have weaknesses and most most people
want to most people who involve really
want to try to improve and these young
kids who need so much help they can see
but these statistical analysis of them
they can see where their weaknesses are
for coaches they're an incredible tool
when you watch other teams play but at
the end of the day if you don't have the
right mix of players you're still not
going to be able to see the goals that
you want and that's why it's so
necessary to make really great decisions
don't spend your money wisely and try
not to make mistakes everyone makes them
if you make an don't try to anyway just
don't want to try to justify mistakes
you have to move on Mitch you made a
mistake and try to not make them in the
future how many would you average with
Golden State right now I have no idea
but with playing with why they play you
get a lot of free easy shots you know
Kevin Durant when he was no coma City
you know they didn't have the same kind
of people around him and he was the
third use used in a fit and number of
shots attempts taken on a team and you
know I you hear you know the people that
are going to have to you know change
their games it was Steph Curry and klay
Thompson they all shot both haven't shot
more shots in Kevin and again it's a
sign of not a not only a great player
but someone who's a great teammate and
that's the beautiful thing when when
people go into the game and when you're
one instead of kind of a house divided
yeah he never took you never took 22
shots in a game in a season never
averaged that you did I think five or
six times where you got at least 22
shots and are you averaged that in a C
well again if you look at the Lakers
when when first came to Los Angeles
elgin baylor was obviously my hero when
i came here and he and after a couple
years if we didn't score 70 points a
night we probably won't have much of a
chance to win it
a fun way to play by the way you know
you're going to get numbers but at the
end of year unless something incredible
happens you're not going to reach the
goals that I take every player who's in
the NBA wants to achieve if everyone
talks about winning a championship it's
the most difficult thing to do unless
you're on a team that packed and plays
the right way well Congrats good luck
with this will you be in the building
when the Lakers play the Clippers I
doubt if I'll be in the building I doubt
if I'll be in the building when they
play the Warriors oh really no no as I
say dad I make light of things like that
you know I'm just I'm thrilled that I'm
involved with Doc Rivers and Lawrence
Frank who I'll be reporting to and also
again who I think has an incredible
owner and Steve Ballmer owners make a
difference and he's going to make a
difference for sure Thank You Jerry it's
great to talk to you again and congrats
on the job
well thank you dad always done nice to
visit with the great Jerry West the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience